is galina lipschitz from georgia tech
and the title of your lecture is
gaussian another perimetry symmetry and
related things
please thank you very much thanks to all
the organizers
it's a very interesting conference um hi
mark
uh yeah i will talk about uh a bunch of
things so let me start
with mentioning sanitation and like i
said some of this
is i don't expect you to memorize it
some of it
but like i said there is a link that
tommy had just posted in the chat and if
anybody wants to scroll back to the
annotation you can scroll back to the
annotation slide or terrain as a slide
uh so um the back measure i will denote
by just two straight lines
gaussian share will denote by lara gamma
uh it's a measure with the density
written here just in case
minkowski some of mostly i'm working
just in euclidean space iran
um nothing more complicated than that
and kowski sum of sets is
defined in the way that's written here
by psi i will denote gaussian
cdf which is written over here some
people occasionally use letter capital
fee
sometimes it's c sometimes i i'm not
sure so anyway use
c uh and there is a few more special
functions written here
just uh that that will be mentioned in
the talk a few times
um uh so let me start with reminding you
about the booming
skin equality uh which tells us that the
volume
of sets in and overall measurable sets
in the dimensional space
of the minkowski average of sets is
bigger
than the average of volumes if you raise
the volume to the power one over n
um so um
it tells us basically that the function
of the volume to the power and run is
concave for the back measure
um and this inequality is very useful i
will mention
so why it's useful but in particular the
modal application is a classical
isoparametric inequality
that tells us the following suppose we
consider all possible sets in iran
of given fixed volume which set has the
smallest possible perimeter
and we've heard a lot of such things in
the manners talk of course
and in this case it's very well known
for many years at least since 1838 that
it's the euclidean bull um and
from bremenkoski inequality you can
prove it really easily
here is a one-line proof provided that
you believe that the perimeter can be
defined in the way that i defined it
here
um you can estimate so basically
the the perimeter is nothing but the
limit of the annulus
of k divided by the width of zenon
so this is how you define the perimeter
in the first equality you can estimate
it from below is the bremenkovsky
inequality immediately you get an
expression on the right which
corresponds to proven the spending cost
inequality
this is quite standard um
let me now put the corresponding slide
in regards to gaussian as a perimetry
so for the gaussian measure there is
this really cool inequality called the
effort inequality
which tells us that if i take the
gaussian measure of minkowski average of
sets and apply
the inverse of the gaussian cdf c which
is written in the
notation side over there then i get
that this function is kind of also
concave
so um
this in particular implies that it it
follows from and implies and there are
all kinds of connections but here is one
way in which it implies the gaussian has
a parametric inequality which tells us
that
if we consider fixed number a between
zero and one
between there and one half let's see but
let me just put
one half just i'm sure because yeah i'm
nervous here okay look
one thing i didn't check okay um
just in case okay um then the
set of the smallest perimeter is a
half space this left half space of the
same
measure the half spaces minimize the
gaussian perimeter
and here is a pretty simple again a
little bit more i would say more
complicated
than in the bernie koski case because of
the lack of homogeneity but still
simple enough proof um you could um
i highly recommend the survey barracuda
on this subject that
um is very expensive um
so anyway you could derive the
problematic inequality from here
um let me and i also did my homework
like
marks had one slide like that and the
manual had one side like this i also
have a slide about connections to
concentration of measures this very
small sample
of things that you could use i had
gaussian
and brunikowski for um you could get the
sharp version of gaussian as a perimetry
you can get the non-sharp version of the
iso perimetry on the sphere if you use
brinkovsky inequality
these are like concentration type
results so if you take a set you
uh you know it so it has large measure
you enlarge it a little bit
um you you know you enlarge it you make
it just a little bit fair how much does
the measure change so this is the
concentration of inequalities
um you can estimate moments of norms of
low concave uh random vectors which is a
very useful result it follows from
parallelism which in turn follows
movement goes skinny quality so this is
like a super small sample
of things which can be useful uh and
hopefully it will
justify me talking about all of the
things
today are there any questions so so far
everything is clear okay thanks
good um with me
so let me uh the method i will not
actually unfortunately mention
anything in detail in this regard let me
just say that the
method uh that we use here is
um based on local of considering local
versions of
all this blue mikowski type inequalities
namely suppose we have
let's say some convex set
and some measure mu
we move our conduct set in time
and namely we push with some constant
speed along each normal so it's like a
gradient flow if you want
um we consider a family family of bodies
kt
defined by this flow locally in
geometric flaws
often they are concerned of on the
behavior of the same when t ghost
infinity
we are absolutely not concerned of this
we only care about what happens for a
very small period of time
if the convex sets strictly convex you
can always
push at least a little bit uh and
then uh the fact that the inequality of
this type holds as
as in the second bullet and here's
equivalent to showing
that for any measure of case a we can
estimate
the second derivative of f over the
first derivative f from above this is
the size of particle file if you want
from above by the derivatives of this
function
um so these things have been in
principle like if i go in
very general terms i'll have to go to i
don't know lagrange and leibniz and
kashi
and you know also bernoulli riemann
but roughly here is a sample of
references that i put on the slide
that are relevant for this method
um kolyzanti considered uh this method
to derive from the bremenkovsky
inequality upon caretaker and equality
in my view the most influential paper in
all of this realm is the one of
kolesnikov and miliman from i think 2018
uh where they actually gave the ultra
proof of the birminghosk inequality
uh back why a study in the local version
so
uh this is a very important uh paper
that has influenced
in particular everything that i'm going
to talk about and many other
developments
um in math so and there are some other
people that i wrote
here as well but yeah um
so um this was very briefly about the
method so
the interesting very interesting
question
i'm not claiming that some the the topic
of the talk i just think it's a very
interesting question
is the question of um bartow donald
hailman
i think morgan asks something like this
there is i'm not quite sure how to
exactly call it after what names but
uh the question is suppose we assume
that the set is symmetric about the
origin in iran
and we fix its gaussian measure but that
minimizes
the perimeter and um
hailman conjectured after bart a long
time ago donald they asked this question
so hellman found a very interesting
plausible conjecture
that says that in fact round k cylinders
minimize the perimeter and by round k
cylinders i call
products of k dimensional n minus k
dimensional spaces
and k dimensional balls so for example a
strip is around k
cylinder when k equals to one a ball is
around k cylinder where k equals to zero
and there is all kinds of things in a
cylinder in three as you imagine it is
around k
cylinder um so basically helmand
conjecture that when you fix a measure
you only need to check two n options
for the perimeter to end because you you
know have all the sets and all the
complements
and i mean all the possible standards
all the possible compliments and
one of them whichever the smallest one
will
be the minimizer and obviously a very
related question
um would be in few of the slides that i
mentioned earlier of course
is if we could find the function in some
sense sharp that
would give us the airhead type
inequality or the brunenkowski type
inequality specifically
for symmetric convex sets that would be
in some sense optimal for cylinders
um i would like to emphasize that
hailman's conjecture talks about
possible symmetric sets not just convex
not just complements of convex
but um basically why don't we just talk
about convex symmetric sets
i mean it's hard enough so uh anyway so
in my view it's an interesting related
question and you know so i think it's
difficult to even make a good conjecture
here but actually i'm going to try to
convince you that
this function that i wrote here is maybe
a reasonable sensible candidate
for such an inequality i cannot prove it
i can make some partial progress towards
it and i can maybe
convince you that this is a reasonable
conjecture so this is pretty much my
goal
um any questions so far
um so let me talk about a different
question about the
symmetry and the supremacy in the
gaussian space
uh so guardians why which conjecture for
any even lock and cave measure and for
all symmetric convex sets
uh this inequality of the form of the
brilliant minkowski
holds and we can raise the measure to
the power one over n
uh if the measure is not concave
basically putting power zero
there is allowed but they conjectured
you can put power
one over and there uh so coach and i are
actually
i showed that you can't replace the
symmetry assumption will say
just that containing the origin in the
interior in the gaussian case
by the way it's clear is that you can't
hope for anything like this to hold
without any structural subjects
whatsoever because your sets if you
if you fix one of the sets and you let
the other set fly away very far to the
infinities and it's gonna obviously fail
so
things like that you should prevent uh
together it's consent impassibility we
showed that locally
nearby variation variant look and give
measures uh another scene
you know this question it might seem
unreasonable
in a way like why something like this
should be true for all even the concave
measures like this is
ridiculous why why why should it be true
it's
not logical but actually it's curious
that it follows from something that's
called the log logankovsky conjecture
which i'm not going to talk about at all
but this that conjecture
is much more reasonable and it's very
logical and very believable so
surprisingly uh you using actually we in
our argument we used also a result of
sargo important here
um we get that yeah this should follow
if we believe in the green koski
conjecture um
together with sasha kalesnikov we showed
that for the gaussian measure and
sets just containing the origin you can
have this inequality with the power
2 n instead of 1 over n so it's a bigger
result however we don't need symmetry
for it we only need that sets contains
the origin
like i said questionnaire said that if
the set just contains the origin
one over n is not possible in fact um
their upper bound was like one of the
square root of pi over two n or
something like this but
there's one over two n uh it works
and that can isos a marquee just
recently proved the very beautiful
result
uh that shows that for all symmetric
conducts at k and l for the gaussian
measure indeed this conjecture of
guardians why which holds it's a
gaussian case this is a power one over n
uh this inequality is um
so let me ask now a tighter question
that would bring us a bit
closer to hailman's conjecture all those
questions about
isopymetry
[Music]
um so a tighter question is
um suppose we want to consider not just
global some powers that works for all
sets k and l
for given measure but suppose we only
want
this inequality to hold for sufficiently
large sets
suppose k and l are for now let's say
symmetrical convex
and suppose the measure is big enough
bigger than a
what is the smallest number that we can
put then and this inequality to hold i
call it ps mu of a
and so it's now it's not a number it's a
function how can we estimate from below
this function tightly
and it's not hard to see that curiously
enough it's enough to
only do a local estimate if we do a
local concavity power for one convex
body k
to be defined as a limit of
the powers for which this inequality
holds then in fact
this ps number is in female mobile sets
of measure exactly a and they can carry
the power of k
um this follows because the class of
sets which
for which me of case is bigger than a is
closed on the makovsky interpolations
i mean it's not not hard to see
uh what's more interesting or less i
don't know what's also interesting
is uh that in principle the lower
estimate on this
beam u number is completely equivalent
to asking what is a perfect
precise best function uh for
such an inequality and it's it's it's
very easy to see
and uh basically whenever we have an
estimate on ps of mu
a uh it means that the function that's
written over here
integral from zero to s exponential
vector of zero to t
this this thing that i wrote here gives
the inequality
uh the opinion and vice versa in
particular
uh from erica's inequality you could see
therefore so f has inequality we don't
need the proof we already know it had
already proved it and
who didn't prove it i mean there is many
beautiful proofs
so uh from that uh even without any
symmetry assumptions we immediately
see uh and actually boss pointed out to
me back um
eight years ago so uh that um
this ps in the gaussian case tends to
infinity when the measure tends to
infinity
so starting from some large enough
measure and i think it's a constant
measure um
we already get actually a pretty large
estimate lower estimate on the concavity
parents
in this woman koski type inequality and
moreover when a tends to
1 when the measure gets larger this
power tends to infinity
and curiously the result of sasha and i
if you analyze it you can see that all
we get there is that if a tends to one
then the power tends to one over two n
we actually made the remarks that
we are annoyed that you know that
this the infinity behavior will be
completely miss out
um and uh in the result of kinesis and
mosquitoes one can
analyze i'm sorry by the way i'm not
most much cheatish maybe
i should say somebody should correct me
um i hope i'm
anyway okay in this result
yeah in this result the limit is 2 2
over n
neither of them is infinity um so
could we try and get an estimate so this
is a
basically i will formulate a couple of
results this result
is simpler in the way it's written
uh but it's not sharp if you think that
the
expression here is not simple it's it's
gonna get worse in a moment but
uh so um one can estimate from below the
concavity part
of the gaussian measure in case
basically
uh the measure of can l is bigger than a
and can have a symmetric on convex
then the following function you can put
in the power
over there or alternatively if you
really want you can write
this in terms of that function that i
wrote with integrals
exact same thing um
so this power is strictly increasing on
the interval one over n to infinity and
we did it tends to infinity when
a tends to one and curiously actually as
a corollary we get the
version of minkowski first inequality
and it's pretty curious that
you know we couldn't be we wouldn't be
able to get it if we had much weaker
bond
and um the version of minkowski
inequality is that if we consider
a convex body k and we add the body out
to it and take a limit
i'm not going to focus on it too much
but i mean i'm sure the experts are
familiar with this object i guess but
uh we can estimate this from building
particular surface areas partial case of
this
thing we can estimate it from below
this expression uh the coefficient here
note instead of one over n we get the
derivative at one of
gamma of the dilate of k
and um any questions so far
now this is sort of the main
thing that i wanted to mention um
[Music]
we can estimate the concavity power for
a given convex body
in terms of a pretty horrible expression
that only depends on moments
second moments of the random vector
distributed with respect to the measure
gaussian measure restricted on k and the
norms k
norms of that vector
the it's horrible i know but the good
thing about this
is that the equality holds if and on the
if k
is this round case cylinder
note that i initially assumed of course
that the set k has c two boundary
i'm not characterizing the quality cases
outside of the c two boundary and even
in the c to bound there is a little bit
of
details required to handle the fact that
a little bit we need some assumptions of
strict convexity at the beginning but we
luckily we only need them in the
inequality where we don't need to
characterize equality cases in order to
end up
with the quality cases in the end and
everything is okay and uh
some basic results in pd allow us to
double actually i will comment on it
in a moment um anyway so this is
an estimate on the local concavity power
for arbitrary convex body in terms of
you know
all these horrible things but the good
thing about it is that it's
sharp and it has sharp and the quality
cases are
similar to the ones in hellmann's
conjecture
moreover the cool thing about it is it
allows us to actually
get exactly the
value for this concavity power for all
those round cylinders
namely if we have a round cylinder
of measure a such that the
ball that we multiply by the space is of
dimension
k we know exactly what the concavity
power for the cylinders this local
concavity power
equals two and here is what it equals to
why
because on one hand if we want this
concavity power to
to to do what it's defined to do
in particular we need uh the dilate
of that set raised to the power to be
concave
because adding dilates is one of the
ways we can
uh take combinations of convex sets and
if we do that and we take this
derivative derivatives and compute
turns out that this expression here is
exactly the same i know
i know but it's exactly the same as that
expression over there
it requires a little bit of integration
by parts in one dimension to see why
this expression is exactly the same but
it's exactly the same
and uh yeah from from above you get and
you you get exactly that bound in the
case of cylinders
and i should say of course that in a
couple of slides i will mention a result
that's a little bit
clearer because of course that theorem
here let me go back to the theorem here
was
we get a result with the quality cases
and then we see how far can we go
to not lose the quality cases and get an
estimate
that's nice so this was a nice attempt
to me
no maybe it failed but anyway
any questions so far
um so obviously the natural question is
if we can take this expression and
estimate it from below by the infimum of
all those expressions for those round k
cylinders
uh from because then com if that
was true then combined with the theorems
that they stated that or anything
something else maybe it was true then we
would get this concavity power
would be minimized on cylinders then we
would get that this function that they
wrote over here
would give us the version of a burn
minkowski record inequality for
symmetric contact sets
and i haven't verified that i haven't
written it later but i'm pretty sure
that this would give
also the um as a parametric inequality
as well
um but i don't don't want to sharpen
tension on that
yeah but this i believe this is probably
clear um
any any questions so far
um so let me
mention a few things about um so now i'm
gonna try and
explain a little bit with those two
theorems that i mentioned
kind of come from but very a little bit
uh
so let me mention a few just a few words
about
energy minimization uh let me recall a
classical notion of torsional rigidity
is particularly well studied in the case
of the back measurement function f equal
to one
it's a supremum over all functions which
are
zero on the boundary of the integral of
the function against
our fixed function f that we fixed
over the average gradient of the
function squared
and there is an interesting thing about
it is that there is some duality here
if you want to take supremum over all
functions
which takes the value 0 on the boundary
of this
ratio it's the same as to taken female
over all functions um
for which i i didn't try that
but luckily max max did this for me i'll
write it later
for which l u equals f l is as in max
stock
is the generator of the measure
uh we are considering the majoristic
okay but i will be talking about this
generator so
um yes there is this
dolly duality it's very easy it's
completely general true in
all kinds of situations
interestingly enough it's been studied
in the back case for hundreds of years
extremely extensively there are books
and books and books about it in the
gaussian case
it hasn't been studied that much you
found exactly one paper
uh i'm not going to tell you the authors
because i only remember one of them
i should do it but they studied
principle frequency
just in one sentence and one remark
actually it turns out for instance that
we can show gaussian analog of san vinon
theorem
pretty easily namely that if you take
function f to be
one then the torsional rigidity would be
maximized on a half space it's
really not not very hard and there is
actually many more things there is
there's a gaussian version of the lenses
inequalities that
don't have time to talk about there is
many things that one can also do with it
um i need to clear
um so in fact the point is that
what what we can show is that in the
gaussian case this
concavity power is bounded from below uh
by
distortion of rigidity with respect to
some f function minus the variance of f
plus
this additional term and here already
the equality holds even only
k is the surround cylinder and
the easiest way to there is actually
several
of them but there is an easy way to
estimate torsional gdg from below given
by this lemma
uh where we simply just um take
the function one minus the square of the
k
norm this function vanishes on the
boundary
so let's plug it in the supreme
definition we get a
lower bound on the torsional rigidity
and
miraculously enough we don't even lose
much if we estimate the gradient of the
norm here in terms of the in radius
well i mean we lose probably plenty but
we don't lose equality cases
so i decided to do that therefore um
anyway so this is this is just the
details
so if we consider f to be one minus
or some constant minus the norm
of k squared we get this you know
horrible lone theorems that i mentioned
theorem two
and if we let f equal to one and just
take torsionality with respect to one
we get and do a bit more estimates here
we get
this very first gaussian theorem that i
mentioned
um that's all there is it of course
raises a few
natural questions um first of all
i mentioned that we can show it's easy
to show that the torsional identity with
respect to one
is maximized uh on half spaces now if we
wanted the set to be let's say convex
and symmetric
would it be maximized on the strip it's
q
just just just a mirror curiosity not
related to anything here
um can we if we take n minus x squared
function
where is it minimized or is it maximized
no idea
um there were two questions here so i
grew okay
some number in here is often so and it
doesn't matter completely parallel
questions that i
haven't had time to thought to think
much but i i'm not sure it's easy
is the i think it's not easy probably is
can we
bound the powers of the norm of the
random vector distributed with respect
to the gaussian measure stick to the
convex set
of the k norm of it if instead of k norm
we had
two norm of course we know that from
above it's completely three vowel
and uh k is a ball from below it's
completely non-trivial and it's a very
difficult theorem of latally nadeskivich
that tells us that it's a strip of case
symmetric and it's
somewhat i don't know trivial material
it's pretty easy also to show that
if you don't have symmetry it's half
space you just need to stand at the very
center
um anyway but i'm curious if you put
norm of k there i have no idea what to
do there
uh another scene uh instead of
considering torsional digit in principle
there is many many
different energy minimization things um
i'm very curious if one could consider
something that one could call like
poncare deficit
uh namely uh suppose we consider well
let's just focus on the expression here
on the left suppose we consider
all possible functions v on k uh for
which
which satisfy the equation that will be
equal to minus v
um there is many many of them if the set
is strictly convex you can solve this
equation with any boundary data neumann
or
um can be it's it's not negative because
of actually things that i will say and
already max
said a lot about and i will say a lot
about as well um
can we estimate it from below it's it
one can show that actually it's also
minimized surprisingly on functions
which are
constant on the boundary it's surprising
that it's a dirichlet
conditioner as a deployment but that's
what seems to be the case
yeah uh how to minimize it how to
maximize it no idea
um interestingly for the usual pancreas
for
the deficiency without the two here if
you put v to be linear functions that
very interesting things happen
um so so somehow i don't have a feeling
that this is the right thing to do but i
have no idea how to do anything
with it at all so but still um
okay um any questions before
so uh let me yeah no
maybe i'm a bit too fast i don't know
so uh let me briefly
explain in a few words why
round cylinders pop up naturally here
they don't pop up here
i mean i didn't make any effort
i already make almost any effort for
them to deliberately pop up here they
pop up completely naturally and they pop
up for two reasons basically cylindrinus
comes from the equality case
characterization that i'm going to talk
about in a moment
in the best complete inequality namely
let me remind you so
max mentioned the corollary of it but
let me remind you the best complete
inequality itself that tells us that if
we have a low concave measure with
potential v
then this inequality is a variance of
any function you can bound from above by
this expression over here
moreover now if instead of you have
arbitrary
v right now we place this arbitrary v as
v times
character
okay we place e to the power minus v
with e to the power minus three times
the
characteristic characteristic function
of k you still have like a low concave
measure
even more low concave so this this
should still hold
um in particular if v is x squared over
two
then you just get the pancara inequality
holds with constant one for any
restriction for for restriction of a
gaussian measure on any set
and it would be actually somewhat
surprising
if you don't think about it a lot even
mark asked about it in
in this concentration group we had
recently so this was all specifically
for mark
here how can it be true if if your
measure is if your set is very close to
the origins of the measures very close
to the back but nonetheless miraculously
it's true and we've heard a lot and
maxes talk about this as well
so cylindrinous comes from a quality
case characterization and this
inequality
now roundness comes from the fact that
the torsional utility is saturated on
functions which range from the bond the
reason there is a specific function
which has to be saturated on the
boundary and it gives us this cylinders
it's it's
these two statements are not i'm
simplifying things a bit but this is
roughly
sort of the story uh so i want to talk a
little bit about
this equality case characterization and
in the press complete inequality
um i'm sure it's probably known in fact
max mentioned the bunch of references i
didn't know and max i want to ask you
maybe i should cite some references that
i don't know about
here it could be that even in this
generality it's known i mean
it's a kind of sense that's easier to
prove than to search for references for
um so anyway so the idea is that
if we consider any local k function
uh this density e to the power minus
fever which is supported
entirely on the rim and the smooth then
for any smooth
convex body k uh
we we have this inequality like i said
it's known but the equality holds if and
only if
either f is constant then obviously
obviously we don't need anything from k
or f is
of this form grad v theta plus some
constant
for some vector theta and k is cylindric
namely it's a direct product of some
sort of smaller dimension and
um some space rn minus k
and this vector theta must be in the
direction of the space
here the case k equal to m kind of
already
includes the situation when f is
constant
it's same thing that there is no such
vector but anyways there's a picture and
any questions about this
i'm gonna um 35 minutes um
i'm not planning to say much more than
this actually so let me just
uh briefly explain why this is the case
mark so you already explained the proof
of breast cancer
inequality using the semi group and by
primary estimate
so here's you will learn in these two
talks in this conference in this
afternoon session
morning session two proofs of breast
cancer inequality if
you didn't want it sorry but
so how does it go so here here is a
hermander streak
of the to to prove the breast complete
bone equality traditionally it's used
without boundary and inequalities it's
it's obtained in approximation for a
convex set but here we want the quality
cases so we want to do every single
boundary
and our our argument relies on this very
important result of kresnikov and
millman which is the extension of the
riley's formula
namely uh first of all we want to
estimate the variance of a function
it's enough to assume that the function
is mean zero
um otherwise we can shift uh secondly
okay finally i wrote the definition of
this operator which you should have
written long time ago uh consider an
arbitrary function
for which function u for which l u
is f this is hermander's trick
there is like i said if we restrict on k
rather than talk about
whole space there is a whole bunch of
such functions and you have just a
equality here
uh if you want by the way to see this
argument written without the boundary
it's a bit simpler you could look for
example to
it that's a paper of fedora skin and
clarity about interpolations of
interpolations and things and generally
this method
is it's a very good place to learn about
this method um
anyway so we write the integral of f
squared in this weird way
we do something slightly weird um and we
integrate the first integral by parts
then for the second integral we use the
valley formula proofed like a less than
of a minimum like i said very important
result they have it in completely
full generality of phaser remaining
manifolds as well so you could actually
do something like this with curvature
which i'm personally not
um particular wasn't aiming for this at
all um
this is what you get okay now you wrote
all the boundary terms now immediately
what you want is to not have any
boundary terms right this is immediate
instinct
luckily we can do this namely we could
let
the normal derivative of the function u
to be zero why because we assumed
that the integral of f is zero so the
system is compatible in this case with
zero neumann data okay let's let's set
it to be zeros and
immediately what we get is something
much simpler
i repeat it on the slide
um and to get brass complete by
inequality now the first guy we estimate
using i'm not sure what to call it
question equality for
experimentally because of that matrix
um we estimate the integral of hash and
squared from below by zero
and uh we use convexity i should remove
this parentheses
we use conductivity to estimate from
below by zero
this expression because second
fundamental form is non-negative
for k for condex body uh
and now if you want to characterize the
quality cases you see here
luckily we don't need to worry so um if
we wanted
it for non-smooth bodies
and i don't know it is uh we just need
to see which inequality
we said we need to make sure that those
inequalities become equalities
so in particular the question is zeros
and
you you must have that u is linear if he
is linear f
was equal to lu which um
gives us the difference of opposite
forms that we want because of the
neumann assumption on you
we have everything about the shape of uh
okay luckily there is no contradiction
in the first inequality and no
conditions
for any quality in this case as well um
so this is it uh the third inequality i
find particularly interesting if we
needed to
do stability we would need to do
stability in every
in all of them it would be much harder
and i actually find it really
interesting one can show that the
equality in this last inequality does
hold
only if it's a cylinder namely
um if equality holds in the certain
inequalities on the boundary of cake and
split and if you associate boundaries
then
can be split into two parts one where
the
normal vectors are organelle to fixed
vector
if you use linear here second is where
um the the second second fundamental
form is singular in particular
the gaussian coverage is zero if it's
the street means gaussian coverage is
here everywhere there is a theorem of
pogoyel of
nirenberg hartmann massive which says
that if the gaussian curvature has zeros
and
it has to be cylinder um but yeah
stability in this i have no idea like
and it's
a much simpler statement also so yeah
something very curious in my view
uh that's it about the gaussian measure
any questions so now i'm
about to say just a few more theorems in
the non gaussian case i'll just say them
very quickly
um so for
any uh low concave measure if you have
locking cap measures twice
differentiable density if only we
assumed that the hash channel fee is
uniformly sticky non-singular
which is let's say it's a strong
assumption but max used it all the time
so let's let's say
i don't feel bad if he's using it i'm
not gonna feel bad
then uh we have that the power in this
inequality tends to infinity
uh as well as so so like i said air has
inequality
guarantees that it tends to infinity for
other measures we don't ever have any
quality but nonetheless
we see that it tends to infinity this is
for symmetric conduct sets
um in a particular case when
the measure has density of the form e to
the power minus the norm to the power p
it's a particular example of a concave
measure
we can estimate uniformly from below the
concavity power by some constant which
is n to the power minus p plus six over
two
horrible constant i'm gonna comment on
this in a moment
um but it's it's a uniform estimate and
in some cases it improves
um in particular it improves a lot for
measures whose density is appearing p
norm to the power p
for p between zero and one uh for p
between one and two
uh in this case we get up to logarithmic
error
something for the one over n so the best
thing we can hope is one over n actually
i didn't comment on it but this
conjecture got in his voice it's about
one around because it's actually
we can't hope for anything better
because near the origin
you get to approximate the back measure
uh so here we get up to a constant and
logarithmic error something of water
whenever an end
it builds up in on
estimates that are similar to all this
estimates i mentioned before and also
the work of binding clark
and this is my last slide
the theorem from two slides ago
is based on the estimate
that i believe again similarly to how
the equality cases of first complete but
probably known to act that is
definitely not experts um if we consider
the one career constant of restriction
of any local isotropic
locom cave merchant view on uh arbitrary
symmetric convex body k
to be defined as in the first line of
the slide it's the best constant of the
function inequality
we can estimate it from above by some
sign of order n to the power
five quarters actually if it's rotation
variant it's
three quarters and um so if
this is not hard it's quite not hard
based on the obviously the estimate on
the
kls conjecture i'll even build up on the
work of the very difficult
well done uh so uh
let me just remark that um if we could
get n here as
an end to the power of five quarters uh
this would have been
the end of it here um
and the example will be for example if
you take a random
polytope isotropic with diameter n
and take um and take the local gift
measure
uh uniform on it and take restriction of
it on something tube near the diameter
we would get something of water and uh
and this extra enterprise quarter again
comes from the fact that
well we don't know kls conjecture so if
scale's conjecture was
true then we would have bound in here
against
not hard cure i'm curious if it's
equivalent
and again i'm sure that experts here
would be like of course yes or of course
no i mean i don't know
but i'm kind of curious if if it's true
that
if we can get the bond of every
restriction as a further end
then necessarily um
one career constant of seistropic
measure locom k would be constant
either way that's it thank you very much
thank you very much galina are there any
uh
questions galena
actually i i have one question um mask
about uh hellman's conjecture
so it is about the gaussian measurement
phase transition of
depending on the volume of the set of
think it was called the annual
formulation
so you know like and and and jumps in
the shape or the dimension of the
cylinder and the
the space uh uh uh jumbo one
um and you know of course um there is
there are similar conjectures for iso
probability problems say for example on
the toes and the cube
and my question is whether you can find
some the regulation definitely this
conjecture so for example you could
there is this trivial map that one if
it's one that pushes forward the
gaussian to the uniform
on the cube this cdf map maybe i don't
know maybe you can get
for helmets conjectures something on on
something equivalent on the
that as a problematic conjecture on the
cube um the fact that you get these
cartesian products of once
of peace one dimension and and uh
so this is extremely interesting what
conjecture on the cube are you talking
about because i don't know
um so if you have uh uh if you look at
just the same
simple on the cube so you have you have
your fix
no no actually no
but no it's not symmetric but if you fix
the measure of a set
with some number between zero and one
you want just to minimize the perimeter
um
so then it's a corner yeah so there are
some jumps kind of if
it's one half so you get the half cube
but at some point it sticks here six
zero
and same thing on the toes so you have
like end jumps
exactly like these engines that you have
here in the helm
now just clearly yeah just but i think
that
i don't think it's proven but i guess
it's conjecture
um this is interesting yeah i i did
i never thought about it maybe exactly
the symmetric version would be relevant
there
you will like that yeah you probably
write it symmetrically
probably my question is it's not so good
because the symmetry is not used
no no no no it could be that i mean it
depends on what the map is i
am if you could send me some links that
would be good actually it's very
interesting i
i don't really know sure uh any other
questions
yeah yeah so maybe i'll ask uh maybe
i'll
say something about what you ask because
i have uh
thought about this worked on this um so
so by the way
so the natural analog is looking at the
conjecture for
real projective space because just as we
know there is an intimate relation
between the gaussian measure
and the sphere then for gaussian measure
for symmetric sets there's
the natural uh finite dimensional cases
rpn
and there again the conjecture is
exactly that it's a it's it's
what are called clifford taurei which
are exactly
cylinders in the real projective setting
right this is the limit and is there
directly
what the hellman's conjunction for the
gaussian measure
i mean if you just yeah of course of
course and exactly the same argument if
you could prove it for a real projective
space
so it's not in dimension three but not
in higher dimension in general
uh for for real projective space um
anyway uh
so this is just to to to say something
about what you asked was
galina but and you're just a few slides
ago you you gave
you analyzed the equality cases in brass
complete
but but just the the version of the
proof of raskamp lib that you gave
it what is the difference between what
we do in the paper with the
with sasha and what you showed is there
a difference um
a beach paper uh you're talking about
the brunei koski paper you prove a
different thing
don't know the the our proof of the
brass complete inequality which
via the rayleigh formula i mean you you
said you know the paper
very well so so you you remember we
proved the breasts
various things and uh
anyway but but one of them was indeed
brass complete
with respect to you know you know cdkn
any kn you know but but that that was
the first paper
okay anyway the history of the papers
okay
there was one there was one uh post on
the archive and then we split it into
two papers but never mind
the the first application we had is
indeed the proof of breast complete
no no equality conditions at all i mean
we didn't care about the quality
conditions okay so
so for me this was an auxiliary result
to get the equality conditions and
thank you very much i will definitely
give the credit i was planning to just
give the credit
um is there anything different
than what we do there i mean probably
not
if you i i i couldn't tell but it looks
no okay here it's easy it's very easy
but it's it's not about
like i agree that it's very very good
sure no i mean modular your beautiful
formula obviously but uh
so if you look at the actually the paper
of boys and dario
uh they have the this argument outline
or without the bond right you can do the
same thing without the boundary
approximate the boundary with the
function
if you don't care about the quality
cases right it's a herman it's called
commander's
group but you know both should comment
maybe he knows better but um
it's much shorter you don't need you
don't need the rally formula you just
need the
you only need actually obviously right
okay so
um and um i believe so i'm i'm sorry if
i
missed a reference on your paper
because i just forgot about this anyway
it's impossible to remember everything
i'm so sorry i'm really sorry no problem
so just so just to set the thing
straight the rayleigh formula
is indeed rayleigh's formula this is 40
year old formula
uh our version was just you know we in
fact were
there was another i mean another version
of this generalized
you know it was a generalized case due
to ding and i forgot someone else and we
basically did one additional integration
by parts
to get it to the form that you you wrote
it's it's you know just integration with
the parts over buckner's formula there's
nothing more to that
and indeed the method goes back at least
to hermander the l2 method
uh you know for proving all of these
many inequalities
i mean just uh there's no need to praise
the formula the whole the point was
the applications of the formula and
anyway i'll if i'll send you
i'll send you the link to this uh today
sure i got split into two papers
okay uh uh indeed so this proof without
the boundary
very classical i guess with the boundary
ramana and sasha did it
the quality cases you can analyze it
pretty easily from this
uh i'm i'm sorry that i forgot that part
of the paper i'm truly
i didn't look at it i'm sorry uh
i mean i don't know i i can't tell you i
i i
i mean i found the paper off wasn't
there and for me this was like okay then
everything else is
straightforward and i didn't look at it
i'm sorry um
no no it's it's their fault that they
did reference i'm kidding boys okay they
were
like it's fine it's fine it's fine
i'm not sure i'm not sure actually i
don't know you were 2018 that was uh
no no that's 2013. it was on the archive
in 2013.
published your paper recession yes it's
anyway there's the history about the the
publishing but
right mr brennan koski it was before my
okay i see
um i didn't say also i mean i uh sorry i
didn't give your credit i didn't give me
credit these are here that
actually i i also had the proof of
mikowski inequality from
but only in dimension to in my thesis
but that was 2015
but that was using harmonic analysis
from the local versions but okay i see
so that was okay you were
very enough
any further questions more
uh question about credit because i think
that the credit for this great lecture
should go to garina so let me take it
again
and we convene uh at 2 p.m in the
meanwhile if you want i think there is
some link to gaza
dot town i think omad put a link to this
uh
thing so if you want to hang around and
you can go there and other than that at
the conference
2pm thank you and bye